[Musique]
roger cetera en fait ils consistent à
réunir plus d'une trentaine d'artistes
de la ville et des villes extérieures
pour la principale cause c'était pour
défendre ce qui a été dit sur trappe en
fait parce qu'on a trouvé que c'était
inadmissible et à chaque fois personne
ne dit rien personne jr et ballon on a
voulu montrer que c'est pas une ville
comme les personnes décrit fond je suis
né ici et tout ce qui a été dit et je
n'ai jamais eu une seule fois et on
dirait trappe c'est si pire que autres
parents paient alors que ça rien à voir
il ya des communautés de partout il ya
toutes sortes de nationalité ils veulent
nous donner plus pour le port du voile
mais les médias ce vol la phase moi ma
vie je l'aimerais toute la ville quand
notre concours ya eu beaucoup
d'histoires ya eu beaucoup de tristesse
et beaucoup de joie mais en tout cas on
n'a pas perdu la foi mais dans le foot
on est tous ensemble d'entendre tout ça
ça nous fait mal vous étonnez pas
qu'après ça finisse mal leur papa à 6
faudrait qui ravale notre mentalité est
génial être appelée rempli talent on est
tous des génies pour pouvoir faire des
achats importants
je suis né ainsi d'entendre ma ville est
critiqué comme ça mais ma mère alitée
ça l'a touché quand même parce que on
vit la nuit tout ce qui est question là
on n'a jamais vu quoi
[Musique]